en el último vídeo de los pulmones y del
intercambio de gases en el sistema
respiratorio de nuestro cuerpo nos
quedamos en los sacos alveolar es déjame
dibujar uno aquí tenemos estos sacos
alveolar es los cuales mencioné
anteriormente están en estos pequeños
grupos de esta manera déjame dibujar un
par más de alveolos para que se entienda
mejor y si recuerdas el último vídeo el
aire atraviesa nuestra tráquea y esta se
divide en nuestros dos bronquios y luego
estos se dividen en los bronquiolos y
los bronquiolos terminan en los alveolos
estos son los alveolos estos son los
sacos diminutos en los que hablamos en
el último vídeo del sistema respiratorio
y te recomiendo ver ese vídeo sin nada
de esto te resulta familiar
tenemos por supuesto a nuestro bronquio
lo conectado a esto y de aquí se
ramifica uno más que acaba en otro grupo
de sacos alveolares pero no quiero dar
muchos detalles de eso porque lo cubrí
en el último vídeo déjame etiquetarlos
brom
yo
luz
estos son alveolos estos son los a
d
los y en el último vídeo vimos que el
aire cuando inhalamos cuando nuestro
diafragma se contrae y hace que nuestros
pulmones se expandan y llenen ese
espacio ingresa el aire y ese aire que
viene será
estamos respirando aire atmosférico
tendrá 21% d
oh sí que no
78% de mí
pero
y de hecho en la atmósfera el dióxido de
carbono es casi un gas traza tiene menos
del 1% de
o dos cada vez que inhalas esto es lo
que obtendrás y dijimos en el último
vídeo que tienes estos capilares estos
capilares pulmonares que están a lo
largo de los costados de los alvéolos
déjame dibujar a esos capilares
pulmonares cuando están de shock siguen
a dos vienen aquí para ser oxigenados
podrían verse un poco morados cuando
están de shock sijena dos podrían verse
un poco morados y van por los costados
de los alveolos y luego toman el oxígeno
que está dentro de los alveolos el
oxígeno se difunde a través de la
membrana de los alveolos en estos
capilares en estos tubos extremadamente
delgados y una vez que lo hace la sangre
se torna roja y hablaré un poco de por
qué se vuelve roja luego se vuelve roja
y ahora que es roja ya tiene oxígeno y
una vez que lo tiene está lista para
regresar al corazón lista para regresar
esta es sólo una pequeña parte de ella
aprendimos en el último vídeo que algo
que se aleja del corazón está se aleja
del corazón
esta es una arteria ha de alejarse
día
y aquellas que van hacia el corazón son
venas esta de aquí es una vez
ahora una pregunta y ésta surgió en el
último vídeo de hecho es bastante buena
cuando inhalamos la mayor parte del aire
es nitrógeno sólo el 21% es oxígeno que
pasa con todo ese nitrógeno ahí como es
que eso no ingresa en nuestra sangre y
esa es de hecho una excelente pregunta
para resolver eso ayuda a explicar lo
que está sucediendo aquí dibujemos esto
un poco más grande déjame dibujar una
membrana alveolar un poco más grande así
este es el interior de mi albiol o esta
de aquí es la membrana es muy delgada
casi tiene el espesor de una célula y
luego tienes un capilar tienes un
capilar que va al costado de ella tiene
su capilar que va al costado de esta
superficie
este es el capilar que va a lo largo del
costado de esta superficie
y así y esto es poroso a gases como el
oxígeno el nitrógeno y el dióxido de
carbono y lo que tenemos aquí es el que
más son
el corazón está por aquí esta es sangre
proveniente del corazón y estaba de
regreso al corazón bueno el corazón está
en ambos lados es que vamos esto pero ve
bien
corazón y
asia
son
y lo que tienes aquí es que cuando
venimos del corazón esta es sangre de su
oxigenada y tendrá una alta
concentración de dióxido de carbono aquí
está el dióxido de carbono de hecho se
difunde en la sangre de hecho se lleva
en el plasma de la sangre no está
cargado por glóbulos rojos hablaremos de
eso en un segundo aquí tenemos un montón
de dióxido de carbono y la concentración
de dióxido de carbono en la sangre de su
oxígeno será más grande que la
concentración de dióxido de carbono
dentro de los alveolos
si esto es poroso al dióxido de carbono
esta es mi membrana y de hecho lo es
estas moléculas de dióxido de carbono
van a difundirse hacia adentro de los
alveolos en el otro lado tenemos oxígeno
lo que inhalamos es 21% oxígeno tenemos
más oxígeno que dióxido de carbono y
está hay sangre de su oxigenada
utilizamos todo el oxígeno en nuestro
cuerpo hablaré de eso ya sea en el final
de este vídeo o en un vídeo futuro de
cómo lo usamos o hacia dónde se va en
nuestro cuerpo pero no hay oxígeno aquí
el oxígeno se difundirá a través de esta
membrana
porque aquí la concentración de oxígeno
es baja
ahora la pregunta es qué está pasando
aquí bueno podemos notar inmediatamente
que conforme el oxígeno se difunde a
través de esta membrana de pronto esta
es sangre oxigenada lista para regresar
al corazón así que esta transición entre
arterias y venas es algo bastante fijo
aquí dices que ésta proviene del corazón
es decir se aleja de él y de
un día
y ésta regresa al corazón así que esta
es una pena
de manera que podríamos marcar la
división podríamos decir bueno una vez
que se oxigena podemos regresar al
corazón o sea es difícil decir dónde
acaba la arteria y dónde comienza la
vena una buena señal es cuando la
concentración de dióxido de carbono baja
y donde la concentración de oxígeno
aumenta ese es un buen momento cuando
empezamos en la arteria pulmonar es un
buen momento cuando empezamos en la
arteria pulmonar
y probablemente en el siguiente vídeo
verás por qué las arterias pulmonares
son especiales porque las arterias
pulmonares alejándose del corazón no
tienen oxígeno o muy poco oxígeno y
tienen mucho dióxido de carbono
y las venas pulmonares
ares
es arbitrario cuando la arteria se
vuelven a una vez que se oxigena está
lista para regresar al corazón es una
vena pulmonar y está oxigenada ésta está
ok sí
nada
y está de shock sí
da
ahora la razón por la cual digo que es
especial además del hecho de que las
arterias y venas pulmonares van hacia y
de los pulmones es que son como lo
opuesto de lo normal porque en el resto
del cuerpo cuando nos alejamos del
corazón o si estamos hablando de
arterias verás que esa es sangre
oxigenada mientras que cuando nos
alejamos del corazón a los pulmones y
sangre de 'shock' sijena da de manera
similar en el resto del cuerpo cuando
regresamos al corazón verás que es
sangre de se oxigenada pero en las venas
pulmonares cuando vamos al corazón está
oxigenada porque los pulmones son los
que retiran el dióxido de carbono y nos
dan el oxígeno ahora bien aún no he
contestado la interesante pregunta
anotada en la sección de mensajes del
último vídeo qué pasa con el 78% del
nitrógeno que está aquí
hay bastante nitrógeno aquí hay más que
oxígeno y mucho más que el dióxido de
carbono que les pasa a todas estas
moléculas de nitrógeno y la respuesta es
que el nitrógeno se puede difundir y de
hecho se difunde en la sangre pero la
habilidad de la sangre para tomar el
nitrógeno no es tan grande y te
preguntarás qué es lo que hace tan
especial al oxígeno porque la sangre
puede tomar el oxígeno mucho más
fácilmente que el nitrógeno y ahí es
donde entran en juego los glóbulos rojos
déjame escribir esto blog
bulos
host
los cuales son fascinantes en muchísimos
aspectos los glóbulos rojos son células
que fluyen a través de todo nuestro
sistema circulatorio y se ven como
pastillas pequeñas si fuera a dibujar
uno son como una esfera plana con una
pequeña hendidura a cada lado de él de
perfil se ve algo así y si pudieras ver
a través de ellos se encontraría es una
pequeña hendidura en cada lado si los
vieras desde un ángulo se vería algo así
con una pequeña hendidura de ese lado
y una hendidura similar del otro lado y
los glóbulos rojos de hecho podría hacer
bastantes vídeos solo de glóbulos rojos
contienen hemoglobina y quizá haré un
vídeo de la hemoglobina únicamente la
hemoglobina es una pequeña proteína que
contiene cuatro grupos hemo adentro de
los glóbulos rojos tienes millones de
proteínas de hemoglobina y las proteínas
de hemoglobina simplemente dibujaré
estas proteínas tienen estos cuatro
grupos hemo cuyo componente principal es
hierro y esa es la razón de su alta
importancia si no tienes suficiente
hierro tendrás problemas procesando
oxígeno en tu sangre y tu hemoglobina no
sería funcional lleva hierro en ella
tenemos cuatro de estos grupos cada uno
de estos grupos se une a moléculas de
oxígeno se enlazan muy bien con el
oxígeno y veremos en el siguiente vídeo
cómo liberan el oxígeno
pero estas tienen millones de grupos emo
en ellas y el oxígeno se difunde a
través de la membrana de los glóbulos
rojos y se enlaza a estos pequeños
grupos hemo en tu hemoglobina debido a
que los glóbulos rojos tienen a la
hemoglobina dentro de ellos son como las
esponjas para el oxígeno porque la
hemoglobina es muy buena tomando el
oxígeno los glóbulos rojos son capaces
de esencialmente absorber todo el
oxígeno del plasma al plasma lo podemos
ver como el fluido general de la sangre
sin incluir a los glóbulos rojos el
glóbulo rojo aquí no es tan rojo y la
razón y este es un punto clave la razón
por la cual no es tan rojo
quizá tenemos un glóbulo rojo aquí el
dióxido de carbono la mayor parte del
tiempo está viajando en el plasma es
absorbido en el fluido
y hablaré de eso en un vídeo futuro esa
es de hecho una forma un poco distinta
que es el ácido carbónico y es un punto
clave para que el plasma sepa
exactamente dónde dejar el oxígeno pero
hablaré de eso en un vídeo futuro pero
aquí este glóbulo rojo tiene bastantes
proteínas de hemoglobina en él pero esas
proteínas de hemoglobina se han deshecho
de su exigen y de hecho resulta que la
hemoglobina con oxígeno la hemoglobina
se ve roja refleja la luz roja cuando no
tiene oxígeno la hemoglobina no se ve
roja se ve un poco morada azul obscura y
esa es la razón por la que en la mayoría
de tu cuerpo las venas que tienen
glóbulos rojos de shock sijena 2 se ven
un poco azules
y la razón por la cual cambia su color
es porque cuando el oxígeno se une a los
grupos se mueven la hemoglobina
de hecho cambia la conformación entera
la estructura entera de la proteína y
hemos visto eso varias veces la proteína
completa se dobla de tal manera que en
lugar de que se refleja luz morada o
obscura ahora la luz roja es reflejada
esa es la razón por la cual los glóbulos
rojos se volverán rojos una vez que
tomen el oxígeno el punto aquí es porque
estamos tomando mucho más oxígeno que
nitrógeno dado que hay menos oxígeno en
la atmósfera que nitrógeno y la clave
son estos glóbulos rojos estos glóbulos
rojos tienen miles de proteínas de
hemoglobina adentro de ellos esta
hemoglobina absorbe todo el oxígeno del
plasma absorbe cerca del 98.5 por ciento
del oxígeno cerca del 98.5 por ciento
del oxígeno es absorbido por los
glóbulos rojos
estos glóbulos rojos están viajando
hacia el corazón y ellos son los que
hacen a nuestra sangre roja tienes a la
hemoglobina que está adentro de los
glóbulos rojos tomando todo el oxígeno
mantiene la concentración de oxígeno en
el plasma bajos y no hay nada como eso
para el nitrógeno no hay una célula que
absorba el nitrógeno el nitrógeno no se
enlaza en la hemoglobina esa es la razón
por la cual el oxígeno es absorbido
mucho mejor que el nitrógeno esa es una
pregunta interesante sí porque si sólo
piensas en la gran cantidad de nitrógeno
del aire es una pregunta bastante
razonable ahora quiero enfocarme un poco
en solo el glóbulo rojo es fascinante en
el vídeo de la estructura de la célula
yo empecé diciendo bien todas las
células tienen una membrana todas tienen
adn lo fascinante de un glóbulo rojo
me hacer una ampliación seguiré haciendo
el mismo dibujo tiene una pequeña
hendidura aquí lo fascinante de los
glóbulos rojos es que ya he dicho que
tienen millones de proteínas de
hemoglobina adentro lo fascinante de un
glóbulo rojo es que no tiene núcleo no
creo
no
no tiene núcleo ni adn esto es
alucinante la primera vez que lo
escuchas y por qué es esto una célula
porque es incluso algo vivo y resulta
que cuando está creciendo si tiene un
núcleo
todos sabemos que todas las células
necesitan un núcleo con adn para poder
generar las proteínas que la forma para
poder existir y estructuralmente hacerse
de la manera que se tiene que hacer pero
el objetivo principal de los glóbulos
rojos es que contengan la mayor cantidad
de hemoglobina posible así que puedes
imaginar que este es de hecho un rasgo
evolutivo favorable porque los glóbulos
rojos están listos para empezar a actuar
hacen su estructura completa y se
deshacen de su núcleo sacan al núcleo de
la célula y la razón por la cual eso es
benéfico es porque hay
más
espacio
para
lo
y nada
entre más hemoglobina tengas puedes
tomar más oxígeno y puedo hacer muchos
vídeos de la hemoglobina y de hecho haré
muchos más del sistema circulatorio
pero quiero mencionar otro aspecto muy
importante de la hemoglobina ahora y ya
hemos hablado de los glóbulos rojos y es
fascinante que no tengan núcleo en su
vida madura de hecho tienen vidas muy
cortas quizá vivan entre 80 y 120 días
es casi una pregunta filosófica están
aún vivos una vez que han perdido su adn
o solo son recipientes para el oxígeno y
no están vivos realmente porque no están
regenerando ni produciendo su propio adn
bueno en lugar de empezar con la
discusión de la hemoglobina en este
momento voy a dejar aquí este vídeo
estoy consciente de que he estado
haciendo vídeos de 20 minutos cuando mi
objetivo real es hacerlos de 10
dejaré este vídeo aquí y en el siguiente
hablaremos más de la hemoglobina y del
sistema circulatorio